previously unfolding ideas with
performance work that's somewhere
between ass fetish and extreme sport or
spending five seconds looking for a
bootleg copy online join me next week as
we dig into the actual videos alright
ladies and gentlemen listen up we have a
fugitive that's been on the run for 90
minutes
ah
your needs right now
and now the thrilling conclusion close
your eyes you're naked in the Guggenheim
hi on three hits of LSD the cream master
cycle plays before you on a 16 inch
television Matthew Barney stands to your
left slightly behind you masturbating a
fake penis made out of hardened
petroleum jelly as the cycle reaches its
climax you have a balloon of nitrous
oxide Barney screams and naked choir
girls poor honey bees all over you in
that moment the cree master cycle makes
sense but what if you're not in that
situation oh yeah then you're screwed
I'm trapped in a dark room
all right everyone get your gonads into
they're fully differentiated positions
it's cream Astor time
crap this is taking too long
you
Hotch is dealing with the title cards
and already who we've run into a problem
so I just ran those cards by in
sequential order but for no real reason
the videos were taped out of order the
actual order was four one five two three
so the question is which order should we
look at the films in chronological or
sequential well Barney wants us to watch
them in sequential order so screw that
we're watching them in chronological
premaster for cream master four is about
a tap-dancing fawn played by Matthew
Barney it's also about motorbikes the
faun tap dances the motorbikes drive
naked women put stuff in his pockets the
motorbikes drive testicles leaked out of
their jackets the motorbikes Drive the
faun tap dances through the four bikes
drive the faun walks around under water
the bikes turn around the faun digs
underground bikes drive the faun crawls
through a tunnel of full of Vaseline
bikes drive women have a tea party bikes
drive more crawling more driving the
faun breaks through the road and we get
a jump cut right before something
interesting happens the drivers tie
ropes to Matthew Barney scrotum credits
roll that takes 42 minutes three master
one cream master one is about a football
stadium blimps chorus girls grapes and
good year played by Marty domination
girls dance air hostesses look bored
good your picks grapes terrible CGI
makes patterns on the floor the chorus
grills mimic the patterns repeat repeat
repeat credits rolled 40 minutes cream
master five free master five is about
opera in Hungarian a stunt double for
Matthew Barney climbs across the arch of
the stage opera a man crosses a bridge
opera climbing opera man jumps opera
climbing naked women opera naked Barney
opera balls nuts testicles junk coin
purse family jewels 45 minutes cream
master two cream master two is a Western
about bees there is a seance Harry
Houdini is arrested by Mounties the
drummer from Slayer plays while bees
the vocalist from orbiting dual screens
and even telephone Gary Gilmore played
by Barney plays with Vaseline in a car
outside a gas station he kills the gas
station attendant a computer-animated
Mormon Tabernacle Choir pretends to sing
Gilmore rides a bowl until they both get
tired died the the summary says they
died a couple does the Texas two-step
around a disco saddle landscape shots
Houdini escapes landscape shots bad
dialogue si landscape shots saddle
credits roll an hour and 20 minutes
cream master three green master 3 is
about Mason's building the Chrysler
Building there some Giants to ya
Destruction Derby in the foyer filling
an elevator with cement faffing about in
a bar more destruction derby girl cuts
potatoes with her shoes slapstick comedy
Barney gets his teeth broken yeah he
gets dentures made out of the smashed
car which causes his anus to prolapse
which then immediately leaks his
swallowed teeth the architect builds two
giant piles of metal plates the tower
turns into a maypole Barney climbs
around the Guggenheim for 20 minutes
while the zany stuff happens back in the
tower Barney kills the architect and
then the tower kills Barney more Giants
credits roll three hours done so let's
go back to the beginning the things that
the cream master cycle does right just
aren't worth applauding and so much else
is done incredibly wrong let's run
through it in order one production
values while the cinematography for
number two and three are the best of the
cycle shot with early HD cameras it's
nothing amazing and is only about par
with what you'd expect from any
competently made film the rest of it is
terrible poorly shot on beta cam that
the visuals are so often praised speaks
more about the fans of the cycle than
the cycle itself their tastes are so
isolated too bad video art that they
fail to realize the visuals of Cree
master are easily dismissed by Blade
Runner Fight Club the fountain and
dozens of other films it's know what
dreams may come and it sure as hell not
the fall does it get pretty at times
sure but it never really manages to
climb higher than talented amateur and
most of it is much worse put simply the
production values are
Parr by any standard that isn't narrowed
down to home movies shot by drunk guys
at the bar the editing is practically
non-existent to the point that it begins
to feel like everything they shot made
it into the final cut whether it should
have been or not there is a clear
attempt at establishing a narrative
where time and space exist and you're
expected to watch the videos from start
to finish but no attempt was made to
pace the narrative or tell the story the
abuse of long shots has the ironic side
effect of undermining the effort into
creating the visuals when you stare at a
gas station for 15 minutes the initial
aesthetics wear off and you have a lot
of time to notice that the whole thing
just looks cheap finally the sound is
horrible a lot could be said about the
bad music and the lack of cohesion
between the soundtrack and the emotional
content of the videos but I'll sum it up
with this noise that plays for most of
Kree master 3
also the onset dialog for cream master 2
is almost impossible to make out because
it was just poorly recorded what exactly
is your discipline to non meaning this
is the subject matter itself even taking
into account the outside information and
how it doesn't actually mean anything
there's three reasons a it's about
gonads that much is obvious but the rest
of it is horoscope messages statements
and images that are so vague in general
that they can be applied to anyone and
anything struggle sure why not there's
no insight here it's not about gender
identity or what it's like to have
gonads or to be a gonad or the struggle
of becoming a gonad it's just about
gonads
B everybody poops almost anyone has or
had gonads so there isn't really
anything special about pointing that out
maybe you'll freak out a bunch of
squares by making a movie about balls
but everyone else is just going to
wonder if you're still 12 years old if
you're more fascinated with having balls
than using them see boring it's boring
to watch
it's about genitals it's not a medical
documentary and it's still boring to
watch the definition of penis in the
dictionary is more titillating it's so
sterile and sexless for a movie about
balls that I'm tempted to consider this
an accomplishment three narrative
control and marketing the narrative of
the videos is crippled by its own
delusions
it's simultaneously too abstract and not
abstract enough this goes back to the
problem of one true meaning that we
discussed in the previous video we are
shown images that don't make sense but
are then told that they have an explicit
meaning you are expected to know what
something stands for but there's no way
to know it without reading the manual
this is Gary Gilmore he was executed in
1977 for killing two men in Utah this is
also Gary Gilmore this is hero mAb if
the architect who constructed the Temple
of Solomon this is the Stu
of the creation of the isle of man I
hope you read the manual first it's all
hobbled by one true meaning specific
meanings are attached but not included
creating a failure of narrative and all
in the name of control Lady Gaga as an
example don't worry this will make sense
I hope Lady Gaga has effectively
weaponized the LGBTQ community in order
to squelch all significant criticism of
her work anything that attempts to
undermine her cutthroat ambition can be
dismissed as homophobic as a result of
the cudgel that she is made out of the
persecuted it's a game of extremes in
Gaga Ville you're either into some kinky
fetish leather or you don't exist this
is relevant to Matthew Barney's work
because he has done the same with Cree
master except instead of the LGBTQ
community being used as a weapon it is
the inner sanctum of understanding
anyone who points out that Cree master
is vapid shallow pointless or bad is
dismissed as not getting it by
weaponizing the discourse surrounding
his work he's attempted to make cream
Astor immune to negative criticism
everything I've said so far can be
written off foldy doesn't get it he
doesn't see the true meaning of the
vaginas that the pigeons are pulled down
through or the proto balls crawling
around the bikes or the long takes of
people looking bored well it's hard to
prove a negative but I do get it there's
nothing there to get it's not about art
because it's not about ideas emotions
experiences or communication at every
possible moment the cycle tries to throw
another barrier up between the audience
and the message because in the end it's
all about the Benjamins
there's two approaches to making money
with art the first is to make art that
entertains or connects with average
people and then hope that you sell a lot
of it at a reasonable price the second
is to make something regardless of
quality and convince a couple people to
buy it for a lot of money you can't
convince people to pay a lot for
something unless you convince them that
it and they are special like maybe you
make them believe that they're the ones
that really get it and you go out of
your way to make the product
inaccessible to the average person just
saying